last night we had the Democratic
gubernatorial debate between Andrew
Cuomo and Cynthia Nixon both vying to
become the Democratic nominee nominee
excuse me for governor in the state of
New York before that debate even
happened a story broke that Andrew Cuomo
had actually received campaign donations
from Harvey Weinstein's lawyers in
exchange essentially for Cuomo
dismissing an investigation into the
actual investigation into Harvey
Weinstein a little back story on this so
you understand what happened here Andrew
Cuomo had directed then Attorney General
Eric Schneiderman to investigate the
folks at in the New York offices who
were investigating
Harvey Weinstein because they knew that
these investigators had also been given
money by Weinstein's lawyers he wanted
to make sure there was no improper
activity taking place within the
investigation that everything was on the
level and that nobody was breaking the
law to protect Weinstein after getting
money and so Weinstein's lawyers come to
Cuomo they understand he's running for
re-election they give him $25,000 for
his re-election campaign and the next
thing you know Cuomo tell Schneiderman
hey you know what you know that
investigation that we just launched
let's go ahead and get rid of that lo we
don't need to do that anymore
everything's cool everything's on the
level we're good here this is the man
that the DNC establishment decided to
endorse over Cynthia Nixon
I mean Cuomo is a guy who was seen
obviously as an up-and-comer in the
Democratic Party you know maybe somebody
who eventually wanted to run for
president as a Democrat but if you ask
me if you want my honest opinion of it
this story about how he attempted to
destroy the Weinstein investigation
because he got money from them this
should be a career ender this is the
kind of
that should not be forgotten and is
certainly not forgivable
Harvey Weinstein preyed upon women all
over this country for decades you know
there's very little question that that
actually happened and now that this
monster is finally being brought to
justice at least in a small way at this
point he's still walking around but
eventually he's gonna have the same kind
of treatment that Bill Cosby got
hopefully far worse because Weinstein
did it to more women that we know of
than Cosby did so the people in New York
have a choice at this point I mean they
still have some time before the primary
and hopefully this story gains some
traction
hopefully Cuomo has to come out and
explain why he took the money and then
immediately killed this investigation
and why he suddenly felt that that money
overruled what all of these women were
claiming happened to them at the hands
of Harvey Weinstein and the Weinstein
group we're living at a time right now
where sexual assaulters people who prey
upon women and try to use them or you
know manipulate them for any reason
whatsoever they're finally facing some
kind of justice most of it at this point
is public justice shaming them you know
having them lose their jobs
destroying careers and these are things
that should be happening to these men to
anyone who behaves in this manner and
preys upon other human beings that
should happen what's also happening and
this is why what Cuomo did here is
equally disgusting is lawsuits are being
filed not just against the people who
did the things but to the people who
helped cover it up the Weinstein group
is being sued I believe Disney is
actually even a part of that because
they worked with him and they knew about
the behavior you have colleges and
universities across this country that
are being sued
because they knew they had somebody
employed at their university that was
abusing students in a sexual way and the
university helped cover it up Jim Jordan
is actually named in the lawsuit for OSU
because he knew about it allegedly and
did nothing so he's been named in that
civil lawsuit as well and when you have
politicians like Cuomo taking money from
the same people that are trying to make
these things go away shouldn't that make
Cuomo just as liable as some of these
other organizations that attempted to
cover it up in my eyes I don't see a
difference here all I see are powerful
men covering up for other powerful men
after money exchanged hands that's what
happened in New York according to these
reports that is what Cuomo did he took
twenty five thousand dollars for his
reelection campaign and then he ended
the investigation into why those other
investigators and attorneys were taking
money from Harvey Weinstein's lawyers
there is no excuse for this there is no
reason for this and this again in my
opinion should be a career ender for
Andrew Cuomo and I just hope that all of
the voters in New York understand this
story completely look into it a little
deeper if you have to but this is what's
going to be on the ballot in that
upcoming primary we need to take a quick
break we'll be right back with more on
the David Pakman show
today's show is made possible in part by
news voice calm / hackman we have talked
on this program for a year after year
after year how american media is
controlled by just a small handful
really of huge corporations and the
problem with having media conglomerates
among others is that you get filter
bubbles you get echo chambers and this
is something I talked about on the
program a lot there's a new media
company that's come up with an
interesting response to this problem
it's called news voice and what it is is
a website and app
for both iOS and Android which gives you
a personalized newsfeed by aggregating a
mix of mainstream media sources along
with international sources and
independent media sources importantly so
any story you look at you will get
multiple sources you can upvote stories
you think are important so that more
people will see them you can add a story
to the site you can add a source that's
missing for a particular story and the
idea is for it to be completely open and
democratized as a source of news and you
can get every side of every story check
out the app which you can download for
free if you go to news voice calm slash
Pakman if you're watching this on
YouTube simply click the link below the
video